hi everybody thanks so much for joining
us Cameron Mathison is here with me and
for Kevin Frazier and that is because
Kevin is in the middle of all the
craziness is we countdown to the Super
Bowl this Sunday on CBS
right and Kevin I think that 1/2 of
Hollywood is there with you Nancy the
star power inside the Moscone Center
here on radio role on the series XM set
is mind-blowing everybody is coming
through and everybody is talking about
the Super Bowl halftime and also they're
getting amped up for the big game there
are a lot of good parties here you
having a party tonight what time do you
expect that party then no we're not
gonna in we're not gonna we're gonna
party all the way up until halftime
Super Bowl how excited are you for
gameday Super Bowl 50
I mean I'm excited to see the state of
me it's one of a couple of times in my
life that I won't go to the game give me
some names of people that are scheduled
to be at the game on Sunday that's Tom
Brady
live at the celebrity kids this year for
sure I mean officer Chris Martin packs
his Moses an apple Blue Ivy is gonna be
here cheering on her mom the Beckham
boys it's gonna be fun next Coldplay
Beyonce and
from the Pepsi Super Bowl 50 halftime
show this is exclusive footage of the
band's preps before Sunday's spectacle
it's just been about trying to bring
everyone together Coldplay Beyonce Bruno
Mars once again this is commemorating 50
years don't forget about that how about
watching Beyonce are you excited for
that because there's a surprise she has
for everybody
I can't tell you I can't tell you she's
pregnant again when she did the the MTV
Music Video Awards Olivia appears an
x-men apocalypse and she's part of the
pre Super Ball super cell just one stars
at what is called a radio row with
something to grow for instance the cast
of Independence Day resurgence stop
thinking about Jerry Maguire when I come
into this room I want to see him just
walking through somewhere go team go
Jenny McCarthy and Donnie Wahlberg
dressed as cheerleaders to get the word
out for her show dirty sexy funny on
Sirius XM radio and Jamie Foxx also has
a serious show and Nick Lachey is part
of a cooking competition
PepsiCo gameday grub match supermodel
Adriana Lima while she is promoting
Victoria's Secret digital who are you
rooting for Broncos